so when it comes to traditional
relationships right
for the past year right I've thought
about this a new relationship contract
and I'm saying pearls held it already
and
um I've said it a few times
but I think
that men and women
because of the times we're living in
should have rolling
contracts for relationships meaning the
two of you should sit down stipulate
what you want in a relationship and have
a rolling contract however long you guys
want it could be a year two years six
months whatever and then after that time
you get to renew it but within that
contract you guys both get to stipulate
exactly what you want out of the
relationship
what'd you guys think of that bad idea
okay why because how now I'm throwing up
contracts for my girl this is not this
is the worst idea ever you drop
contracts for for marriage yeah I know
but in listen and that doesn't work so
tell me 50 50 50 50. so put if you're
drawing a contract in a relationship and
a boyfriend a girlfriend scenario it's
not that deep so basically everyone is
single until you're married like that's
everyone's up for game the only way I
know that you not to approach you if
you've got a ring on your finger so when
someone says oh I've got a man
yeah but we're living in a time now
marriage doesn't matter people people
are having whole affairs with them with
them
the reason why I'm coming up with it is
because my thing is
there has to be a solution to the times
that we're living in okay and so we
can't keep trying to fit a square peg
into a round hole if it doesn't fit now
I know everybody keeps talking about
marriage marriage marriage marriage
marriage but when you look at the
statistics it's not working so I'm the
type of person who sees something
Caesar's not working and offers a
different a different perspective now it
may not be the right perspective but
what everybody can see is that this
thing is not working so if it isn't
working
what's the new model so it's marriage
without marriage this marriage without
matter yeah
so then we should just do what we're
doing already now because end of the day
it's a little bit more yeah well on the
other side it Advocates more for the man
that's that's basically what Sarah is
saying but then I mean even nowadays you
have one in four marriages that are
sexless so men get married thinking
they're gonna have sex and they don't
even have sex and she puts on a lot of
weight after she gets the ring and then
you know she leaves you and takes half
yeah and then within the contract yeah
you'd say you know you wouldn't be able
to kind of gain a certain amount of
weight you wouldn't be able to know him
inside or not why not I will why not
a certain amount of sex it's up
it's up because a lot like Pearl was
saying a lot of making
it a quarter of marriages are sexless so
why would I get into an into a
relationship knowing I'm not gonna get
sex as a man well that's one of the
things that we love and it's interesting
because I understand like what you're
saying because you know I I do in a way
because I I do like I think marriage
like it was a good thing in my life
right like for my parents were married
most people I know were married but the
thing is like the more I learn about the
contracts I'm like I could I could see a
guy being very devoted to a girl being
with her for 10 plus years and just no
ring because it's a bad contract to sign
so you're willing to be a baby mama then
no no no no but I think legally you know
but that's what I'm saying I don't need
it legally but I I think like not being
having a part of the government that's
fine no but if you can't if it's not
married in your church
okay okay cool like me personally okay
so if we get married in the village in
back home
um it's going to be similar to what
you're trying to say right but you're
still legally married to each other do
you understand what I'm trying to say to
you I think what we're trying to do now
is we're trying to create new
definitions for what marriage is
supposed to be and what relationship if
that's the case then just and then just
do what you're doing you don't have to
actually have a contract I think they're
just trying to find a solution for a bad
deal no right now the contract is a bad
deal for men so just be single and just
that's what a lot of guys are doing yeah
but that's cool that's what I'm saying
I'm saying so a lot of guys are doing
that but marriage nowadays like If we're
honest with ourselves if we're actually
honest with the society in which we live
in marriage is a joke and when I say
that it's a joke do you know why because
marriage is a TV show
Love is Blind 90 Day Fiance
Married at First Sight marriage has
become entertainment
it's not there's no sanctity in it
anymore so when the same women that are
sitting down to watch Married at First
Sight and love is blind and nighty Day
Fiance the same woman saying oh yeah I
want to get married you're literally
watching marriage as a TV show it's not
there's no sanctity to it anymore and so
that people can literally say okay I've
got 90 days to get a visa to to marry
this woman that's not marriage yeah but
so I don't think I like yeah that's
marriage is a joke so so if we're gonna
say marriage is a joke based upon Night
and Day Fiance like nah man you need to
stop watching it's based off of the
numbers it's based off of one in four
marriages are sexless one in four the
average length of a first marriage is
seven years and it gets smaller and
smaller based on how many marriages
there are it's based on the fact that
the men are paid women are paid to leave
and take half and take your children
that's why it's a joke it's not it's not
based off of a TV show yeah so I hear
what you guys are saying I hear what
you're saying but
um now
seriously think about it is it because
it doesn't feel nice to you that's the
thing it doesn't feel it doesn't feel
nice and I understand where you are
because I was there at one point too no
I could listen I haven't gotten to my
age or not had any kids because I don't
because I can't come on like I've got in
here because I don't want to have a baby
mum's and I could easily have like my
friends have baby mums but I've seen
what it's done most of these kids that
are growing up doing the madness on the
on the road now they they're coming from
single parent homes
so even this thing over you're talking
about if it's not marriage it's not
gonna it's gonna be the same thing that
we're seeing right now so when we're
trying to go out now and say you know
what actually let's not get married
let's write a contract why are you gonna
keep to the contract it's not because
because the contract is more um it's
more individual whereas a marriage uh
contract is more broad like we said men
when it comes to marriage they get the
short end of the stick if the marriage
breaks down like I said I said 50 50
before you didn't like the um the
airplane allergy but that's what it is
like marriage goes to a train what a
train yeah yeah it's not a train is it a
plane is an automobile because
everything that you every knowledge that
you give towards America includes death
and I
a lot of guys commit suicide because
think about think about put yourself in
those guys shoes you work for 20 30
years you're still young you lost
everything tomorrow you could still
build it back yeah but I'm not right but
I'm saying this guy is 55. his wife
leaves him if he has children that are
still under the age of 18 she takes the
kids he and she is paid to take them and
give him less time and then he has to
start from scratch at 55.
yeah he took an l yeah for women though
let's remember that women do have like a
hard time in in divorces sometimes it's
not I know I know you know girl how
how you've built the man up to what he
has yeah
I hate it when girls
no no why don't we take credit for men's
success if your guy was successful he
was going to do it with or without you
we didn't build anyone else we didn't
build anyone up my dad is a top one
percent earner I grew up around these
top one percent five percent man I
promise to God they love their wives
their wives are there for them but they
would have been rich with or without
them
so if you built this man right yeah if
you're building this manner
I'm just using it
so if you if you built this man yeah and
you're saying this man is only
successful because you built him yeah
and and and imagine that no I don't like
that that's not what all right but let's
just say that that let's just say that's
the Pavilion psychology of certain women
right why is it now if women feel that
they've invested into a man and built
him up why are they the ones that 80 of
the time that are filing for divorce
because if I if I if I invested in
something educated
why leave it I can't talk because every
every relationship's different I don't
know what's going on in the particular
you know I mean in those num in those
statistics I don't know what happened so
I can't really I can't really do you
know what I mean but I know that yeah I
just wanted to just remember we're not
it's not just oh the man's depressed and
you know lost everything there's a lot
of women that end up in the gutter after
after divorce and men that leave their
wives as well not just women that up and
take everything well even even if they
do leave they're legally protected men
aren't so even even if a guy does you
know trade you for the younger model or
whatever yeah
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible